[Music]
jim is with us in tampa florida to kick
off this hour hey jim how are you
how are you guys doing great how can we
help
wonderful well dave the first thing that
i'm going to ask for you
is to uh not yell at me for making a
stupid financial decision that i'm about
to tell you i have a rule the first
caller of the hour i never yell at them
so you're in luck
dave you know i have been following your
uh financial principles for uh um for a
while now
uh and um right now uh we're on baby
step six so we're almost done paying off
our home
we're actually um you know probably by
either
the end of this year or the beginning of
next year we'll be paying off our home
so we're really we're really good on
that
wonderful um i am very upset
because um uh we
puzzled into a time share you what and
you already know where this is going you
want into a time share
we got well okay so we got invited to
one of the timeshare presentations
and you know i'll be honest with you i
was really um
i was just really ready to say no my
wife was with me and they were painting
a picture to her that i'm not trying to
blame this on my wife by the way
but you know they were paying me a
picture to her that i was like oh
goodness you know i mean it's kind of
hard to say no
here's my point um you bought it this
was last year
this was like this was last year and we
said well okay i guess we're going to
get one so we got one
and um i mean i we actually already paid
it in full
and um you know my question is
should i still try to get rid of it
because honestly i'm just upset at the
fact that i even got it
or should we you know sensations we
already paid for it and i know we still
have the maintenance fees and all that
kind of stuff
yeah should i maybe try to take a little
bit of advantage to it you know
advantage of it you know before i decide
to get rid of it
you probably don't hear that you know
hey i have a paid for
timeshare yeah we do but i don't hear
people about right pay off their house
should get
who go and buy a time share very often
but i know no and that's
fairly unusual really upset about that's
the part i'm really upset about
jim did you initially say that you got
hustled into buying one
well yes so when we got into the
presentation when we got into when we
got into the presentation
really nice people by the way uh but you
know they were like you know
they won't take no for an answer yeah
they're just playing so because and so
and so because of that it was like well
okay you know and then we're just like
okay you're trying to be nice but at the
same time you don't want to get ripped
off
so you know i mean with uh jim settle
down
do you and your wife use this thing well
they just got you know
we we just got it okay yeah
i mean it's completely up to you brother
whatever you want to do
i think that what you're going to
discover is what 97 of people discover
the time shares suck and the the fees
are going to go up and you're going to
feel trapped into using that unit you're
all the stuff they promised you about
being able to trade points with somebody
else is not going to happen
and yeah the industry is scummy scammy
and
bad news and you're not going to get
you're going to discover you're not
going to get delivered well you were
promised and told by those sweet people
who are pressuring the crap out of you
which is kind of an oxymoron if you
think about it but um
the uh uh so i mean you know if you want
to play with it for a year or two and
discover that all this for yourself
you do whatever you want to do man it's
your money i mean but um
i i think you're going to get not only
increasingly disgusted with yourself for
having bought it
but increasingly disgusted with the
whole process
yeah and i think that's what you'll
discover but it's okay if you wait until
you get there
before you pay times your exit team to
get you out you know
right right right well initially i was
hoping oh man you know
uh maybe i can get like a refund
especially during these times that i
know that that's not realistic
not from those people yeah and so i
would give anything
i would i would give anything to uh you
know to go back in the past and you know
not do that but you know they don't let
fish off the hook once they got one so
i think you're just gonna wallow in it
until you get disgusted enough to pay
somebody to get out of it but you're not
only gonna lose the pay the fee you pay
times your exit team to get out of it
you've lost all the money you put into
it so you know given all of that you may
want to
like chris said you may want to play
with it for a year or two and just see
but i think
i think what you're going to find is
you're going to get increasingly
disappointed in the organization because
they're scummy and scammy
yeah and and i would say this dave i
think we all have to go through our
stupid tax phases
we all have to and i think the learning
thing from that is all right a couple of
things
i tell people you want to make two year
decisions you want to make a decision
that you look back on in two years and
you're glad that you made it
and if it sounds too good to be true my
friends
then it is it truly is you know there's
um the industry
in the timeshare industry is widely
known
for putting you into a room and
pressuring you
like no one else like no other business
does
and lying and cheating and making
promises that they don't keep they've
had hundreds of thousands of dollars of
fines
they've settled lawsuit after lawsuit
for fraud
it's a known scummy business
most people kind of know that jim knew
that
and then if you know that then there's
uh
there's another part you need to know
and do you know yourself well enough to
know that you have trouble saying no
now me i i mean i do talk radio i eat
conflict for breakfast yeah you don't
have any problems i don't have a problem
saying no
no you don't no chris i've heard that a
lot
i can just say no i mean i've gotten
real comfortable in my own skin
real comfortable so i'm not even going
to be in the room to start with because
i don't want to be in a room where
people have to take a shower
after i'm in the room with them but dave
it's a free dinner and so it's
it was a free vacation for the weekend
in a in a crappy butt little dumpy hotel
room
and so just go buy you a crappy butt
little dumpy hotel room you'll come out
much better off but
if you know about yourself like i know
about myself that i don't have any
trouble saying no
i'm still not going to enter it just
because i don't like being around that
kind of people they're just gross
right but then in addition to that if
you're just a person who says i you know
my wife is that way she can say no
but she's she wants to be she wants to
avoid conflict let's everybody
happy you know everybody's not going to
be happy and so she would be in there
if she knows that about herself she she
knows if she goes in that room she's
about to get
she's about to get tattooed it's going
to come off bad that's right
and so if you know about yourself that
you have trouble saying no
that's right for god's sake stay out of
those rooms
because you're gonna come out there
owning a freaking timeshare hey dave
it's like my buddy every
year at the beginning of the year he
would go look at
trucks yeah i told him one of them
is gonna jump the keys are gonna jump in
your pocket go get the payment
he didn't didn't hear from him for two
weeks i said what happened we made a bet
he goes
i got the truck i said you got that
payment didn't you i said stop looking
dummy
go home people will read consumer
reports and study
for for 73 hours on which 600 dollar
phone to buy
and then they impulse an 80 000 porsche
the same dadgum guy that's a problem
it's a problem if you
know this about yourself protect
yourself
from yourself that's a good rule because
otherwise you get you get to you get to
have these
problems and i'm so sorry jim sorry you
got this mess man
but you'll you'll figure it out you'll
wonder you'll get to it this is the dave
ramsey